[Music]
the villainous dr. Schrodinger has
developed a growth ray and intends to
create an army of giant cats to
terrorize the city your team of secret
agents has tracked him to his
underground lab you burst in to find
that it's a trap dr. Schrodinger has
slipped into the next room to activate
his device and disabled the control
panel on the way out fortunately your
teammates are masters of spy craft agent
Delta has hacked into the control panel
and managed to reactivate some of its
functionality meanwhile agent epsilon
has searched through surveillance to
find the code for the door to 10:14 all
you have to do is enter those numbers
and you'll be free but there's a problem
the control panel has only three buttons
one which adds five to the display
number one which adds seven and one
which takes the square root you need to
make the display output the numbers two
ten and fourteen in that order it's okay
if it outputs different numbers in
between but there's no way to reset the
display so once you get to two you'll
have to continue on to ten and fourteen
from there not only that agent Delta
explains that there are other traps
built into the panel if it ever shows
the same number more than once a number
greater than sixty or an on hole number
the room will explode right now the
display reads zero and time is running
out there's only one way to solve the
puzzle with a few small variations
how will you input the code to escape
from dr. Schrodinger's lair and save the
day
answer in three two one you look over
your options adding five or seven
increases the number and the square root
button will make it smaller but there
are only a few options where you can use
that button 4 9 16 25 36 and 49 you'd
love to make 4 or 16 then you could hit
the square root button once or twice to
get to but you can't make either with
just the 5 and 7 buttons what will you
do you look at the other possible
options for numbers you could take the
square root of 9 you can't reach 25 and
49 would take you back to 5 or 7 and you
can already get to each of those 36 is
your only option
you add five seven five seven five seven
and then hit the square root button why
that series of fives and sevens
it's somewhat arbitrary but you know
that you want to avoid 10 14 and perfect
squares since you'll need them later
this gets you to 6
does that help looking at your options
you see that 16 is now in your sights
you add 5 twice more to reach it then
hit square root twice that gets you to 2
you're on your way now to 10 you can't
get straight there through addition
alone so you're going to have to reach
another square taking the square root of
9 or 25 would get you to a good place
but it turns out that 25 is unreachable
from 2 so you add 7 to get to 9 then
take the square root again that gets you
to 3 adding 7 again makes 10 finally you
need to reach 14 thinking backwards you
imagine where you could be before 14 7
or 9 but 9 won't work because you've
already used 9 however you could get to
7 by reaching 49 first you add your way
towards it being careful not to hit any
of the numbers you've hit so far you
thread your way carefully adding 5 5 s
and two 7s then square root to 7 and add
seven more the door opens and you're out
of the trap
thanks to your problem-solving skills
your team gets Schrodinger's cats out of
the box in the nick of time
as for Schrodinger you can be certain of
one thing he'll be spending quite some
time in a box of his own interested in
navigating another maze of numbers try
this one out you need to get from 11 to
25 and the only operations available are
multiplying by two or subtracting three
what's the fewest number of moves that's
possible in this puzzle comes courtesy
of our sponsor brilliant org brilliant
is a great way of honing your
problem-solving skills and learning from
a community of fellow math enthusiasts
it features a lively
discussion where people have explored
this problem from a variety of
approaches including how to take it one
step further
join the conversation today at brilliant
org slash ted-ed or click the link below
to enter your answer to the bonus riddle
and if you sign up for a premium
membership using one of our links you
can get 20% off the annual fee